bonsoir merci d'être avec nous karine
déchets goal of co tout d'abord cette
déclaration fraîche 1 du président
bélarusse alexandre loukachenko qui
estime que si son régime tomber la
russie suit vrai que vous inspire cette
affirmation ce qu'elle consent bloc
crédible bon sur cette affirmation me
semble en effet pleine de bon sens
malheureusement parce que lorsque l'on
voit les crises qui se développe aux
frontières de la russie
petit à petit il est évident que la
russie fait l'objet d'une opération
d'encerclement de la part du plan global
istin avec l'aide de l'otan
donc après l'ukraine il est tout à fait
logique que la la biélorussie et d'été
attaqué la période électorale comme à
chaque fois est toujours privilégiée
puisque c'est une période qui permet de
jouer en fait sur la transition du
pouvoir
et si la transition ne permet pas de
mettre en place un candidat qui soit
sûre européen
dans ce cas là c'est l'occasion de
faiblir afin de faire tomber un système
tu vas te faire tomber un système qui
est déjà affaibli puisque en général et
les systèmes politiques sont assez
affaibli en ce moment
sauf que en occident ils sont pas sous
pression des révolutions qui sont déjà
d'un peuple badistes donc effectivement
derrière les vélos et s'il a de fortes
chances que soit l'heure le site
puisqu'il ya une configuration politique
qui ressemble à en quelque sorte c'est
beaucoup de traits même si la russie a
beaucoup plus de force que le biologiste
alors aujourd'hui ans est l'une des
déclarations également de la soirée en
paris condamne les arrestations qu'elle
définit comme arbitraire et l'exil forcé
d'opposants via le ministère des
affaires étrangères qu'elle peut être je
mens l'image
la marge de manoeuvre de ces pays dont
la france dans cette affaire biélorusse
la marge de manoeuvre et c'est de la
volonté ses dirigeants le problème étant
de savoir que manifestement ils n'ont
qu'une envie de regarder ce qui se passe
lorsque l'on parle de l'exil forcé c'est
assez surprenant
est-ce que tu rames ce qui a été obligé
de partir ou bien les parties elles
mêmes tout seul très rapidement
d'ailleurs lorsque manifestement comme
attendu elle a perdu ce qui d'ailleurs
était prévu et ce qui était nécessaire
pour pouvoir lancer toute cette affaire
en ce qui concerne le départ des trois
membres du conseil de coordination de
l'opposition
il ya différentes aires ci ont quand
même qui circulent parce qu'il ya la
version à magnifique romanesque
fabuleuse de ses opposants qui ne veut
pas partir qu'ils sont obligés qu'ils
ont été obligés de prendre avec eux dans
leur dans leur voiture quelques caresses
nicolas qui a été partie du présidium de
cette de ce conseil
anrig a aussi une autre version
pas du tout celle où cette jeune femme
forcé à partir en ukraine sort de la
voiture des sites déchire son passeport
et se dirigent courageusement vers le
kgb
il ya celles qui est plutôt dévoilée par
les garde-frontières qui explique à 4
heures du matin veille qu'il voyant que
le contrôle aux frontières avec
l'ukraine été renforcées a foncé vers
des gardes-frontière que afin de faire
une vidéo de diversion et de pouvoir
passer ces deux charmants amis de
l'opposition l'ont littéralement jeté en
dehors de la voiture ce qui a conduit
effectivement à son arrestation c'est
une vision qui est quand même beaucoup
moins belle mais qui permet d'expliquer
aussi pourquoi tout à coup il ya à
nouveau des manifestations tout son
soutien à l ils ont enfin une victime
s'écrit fille que tu iras lorsqu'un
depuis le temps qu'elle et à l'étranger
commencent à avoir du mal à remplir sa
fonction
enfin une chose est sûre c'est que la
contestation rassemble environ un cent
mille personnes chaque jour dans les
rues de minsk s'est tout même un message
qu'il faut entendre la part du pouvoir
il ya effectivement un message à
entendre on a vu aussi la différence
entre peut-être l'aspiration des
ukrainiens en 2014 et ce qui a été fait
une fois que le pouvoir a entendu
message et sous l'égide de pays
européens a signé un accord avec
l'opposition pour ensuite le lendemain
être persécutés et de voir s'enfuir du
pays s'il m'en être assassiné la
question de savoir est ce que cela va
aider la biélorussie si loukachenko
reprenant l'expérience ukrainienne 2014
va à nouveau discuter avec l'opposition
sous l'égide des européens en risquant
lui aussi il ya de fortes chances
derrière effectivement de 2 vers le
devoir s'enfuir
quel sera l'état de biélorussie après
quand on regarde l'état de l'ukraine
aujourd'hui donc le changement c'est
très bien mais la question tant de
savoir pourquoi
loukachenko est tout à fait conscient
d'ailleurs il l'a déclaré dans son
interview aujourd'hui que des satins
petit peu longtemps qu'il est au pouvoir
et ça c'est le problème effectivement de
ceux de ce régime c'est que il est
concentré autour s'est concentrée autour
d'une personne et lorsque vous avez une
figure très forte qui a demandé qui
domine d' espace politique
objectivement une réelle opposition a du
mal à se développer mais il faut voir
aussi que l'occident aime beaucoup ce
genre de configuration
lorsque ça permet de dessécher et
d'affaiblir le pays de l'intérieur
et lorsque nous cache un codic derrière
la biélorussie c'est là aussi parce que
cette question se pose aussi en russie
et l'on voit la grande difficulté de
transition de l'après poutine en russie
donc les questions se posent oui il y a
un problème
mais est ce que ça veut dire que il faut
absolument tout accepter tout et
n'importe comment
lorsque l'on voit aussi quand même qu'
il y à sers beaucoup de personnes dans
les rues sur les chiffres c'est toujours
une grande difficulté quand même pour
apprécier les chiffres
donc on va pas rentrer dans les détails
il ya du monde c'est ce qui compte
mais
la question fondamentale qui reste étant
de savoir dans quelle mesure est
complètement naturel ou n'est-ce pas
aussi passablement manipuler rappelons
quand même qu'il ya quelques millions
d'euros qui ont été débloqués par
l'union européenne sous couvert de lutte
contre le vide qui sont adressées
directement la société civile parce
qu'il est évident que quand vous êtes
malade et où sony pour une ong
merci karine michel collot vaut d'avoir
été avec nous avoir apporté votre point
de vue votre analyse en direct assure rt
france